es un día de cooperación en Estados
Unidos es el día de los veteranos los
veteranos estadounidenses y sus familias
sobrevivientes cuidadores son la espina
dorsal son el alma de los Estados Unidos
y en esta ocasión tan especial en todos
los días
otro aquellos que hicieron su sacrificio
Por nuestra nación como mi hijo Quiero
agradecer
aún veterano particular
un servidor público amigo literalmente
uno de los hombres más condecorados
el enviado especial para el clima el
señor John Kerry John
tu compromiso tu pasión tu experticia
diplomática han sido absolutamente
cruciales
cumplir con un progreso significativo en
el tema
medio Ambiental de los últimos años
quiero agradecerte por ser mi amigo
Este es un testamento los milenios de la
ingenidad humana vemos como una misión
evitar la catástrofemática y ver cómo
crece una economía climática nueva no
solamente como un imperativo para
nuestro futuro sino a los ojos de la
historia
de acuerdo con la Organización
meteorológica Mundial en los últimos
ocho años
han sido los más cálidos en el registro
los Estados Unidos en Estados Unidos
estamos viendo una sequías históricas
incendios en el occidente huracanes
devastadores y tormentas en el este aquí
en África
África que es hogar de tantas naciones
consideradas las vulnerables al cambio
climático sufren de seguridad
alimenticia cuatro años de sequía en el
acuerdo de África también Mientras tanto
el río Nilo en el oeste de África
está lleno de agua por tantas tormentas
y está causando caos en comunidades de
pescadores en Nigeria las inundaciones
mandaron recientemente 600 personas 1.3
millones de personas están siendo
desplazadas
las rutas migratorias para el ganado que
se ha utilizado por
cientos de años se están
convirtiendo en lugares de conflicto
entre granjeros y otras figuras la
crisis climática se trata de la
seguridad humana la seguridad económica
seguridad medio ambiental seguridad
nacional
y la vida del planeta en sí mismo hoy
Quiero compartir con ustedes como los
Estados Unidos están
enfrentando esta crisis climática Con
urgencia y con determinación para
asegurarse de que haya un planeta más
limpio más saludable para todos nosotros
durante mis primeros días en el cargo de
administración lideró una agenda
bastante intrépida para enfrentarse a la
crisis climática y la seguridad
energética en el país y en todo el mundo
inmediatamente
nos encontramos al acuerdo de París
creamos bastantes reuniones climáticas y
restablecimos
por si me descubro por haber salido del
acuerdo establecimos
un foro de grandes economías para
pedirle al países en todo el mundo que
aumenten sus ambiciones climáticas el
año pasado el cop 26 en Glasgow los
Estados Unidos ayudaron a cumplir con un
compromiso crítico que llevaría dos de
tres tercios de producto interno bruto a
limitar el crecimiento del calentamiento
global
Durante los últimos años Estados Unidos
ha cumplido con un progreso imprescente
en el hogar
a través de unas grandes inversiones En
infraestructuras estamos
Estableciendo una nueva red energética
decimos expandiendo las redes de tráfico
que estamos construyendo redes
nacionales y de recarga de vehículos en
todo el país este verano Estados Unidos
El Congreso aprobó
una propuesta de ley
para la mayor acta climática en la
historia del país
la acta de inflación reducción
la acta de reducción a la inflación
[Aplausos]
incluye menos de lo que pedí pero es una
cantidad significativa 368 millones de
dólares para respaldar
la electricidad limpia
desde la energía solar hasta la energía
lógica eólica vehículos
voladores sostenibles
procesos limpios de manufactura
agricultura inteligente con el clima
reforestación y mucho más nuestro
departamento de energía estima que hay
en esta nueva ley podría reducir las
emisiones en Estados Unidos por
alrededor de
mil millones de toneladas en 2030
y creando una nueva etapas de
crecimiento verde nuestras inversiones
En tecnologías de baterías eléctricas
este hidrógeno para iniciar un ciclo de
innovación que reducirá los costos y
mejorarán los desempeños de la energía
limpia esto estará disponible a las
naciones de todo el mundo no solamente
para Estados Unidos vamos a ayudar
vamos a ayudar a llegar a esa transición
a un futuro de bajas emisiones de
carbono que sea más accesible para todos
vamos a acelerar este esfuerzo Más allá
de nuestras fronteras de hecho la
agencia internacional de energía incluyó
recientemente que nuestra inversión
climática cito ayudaría a recargar
ayudaría a recargar
la
economía limpia en todo el mundo estaba
leyendo esa cita discúlpenme Esto va a
cambiar el paradigma para Estados Unidos
en todo el mundo
también ratificamos
el acuerdo de aquí para reunir el mundo
en contra de la producción y el uso de
hfc
hay muchos daños en estos gases Apenas
ayer Estados Unidos se convirtió en el
primer gobierno de requerir
a nuestros mayores
suministradores federales
para que cumplan con las líneas
establecidas por el acuerdo de París
como el mayor cliente del mundo con más
de 650 mil millones de dólares en gasto
el año pasado Estados Unidos el gobierno
de Estados Unidos está poniendo el
dinero donde están sus palabras
fortaleciendo la resiliencia climática
estos pasos críticos ya
están logrando infracciones diversiones
importantes en nuestro resultado para
disminuir el costo de la energía Limpia
para crear trabajos bien pagos en
Estados Unidos y avanzar en la justicia
medioambiental en nuestras comunidades
damas y caballeros
estamos comprobando que una política
climática buena es buena económicamente
también es un buen fundamento
para una crecimiento económico inclusivo
resiliente está ayudando a progreso en
el sector privado estando Progreso en
todo el mundo
y el total de las acciones que
administraciones está tomando por
Estados Unidos en camino a cumplir con
las metas del acuerdo de paz de reducir
las emisiones al 50%
Jordi de aquí a 2030
Déjenme tomar un momento para enfatizar
lo importante lo significativo que es
poder decir esto
presente la primera legislación
ambiental en 1986 en el senado de
Estados Unidos hace 36 años mi
compromiso con este tema ha sido
incesante y yo y finalmente gracias a
las acciones que hemos tomado puedo
ponerme aquí de frente a ustedes como
presidente de Estados Unidos y decir con
confianza que los Estados Unidos de
América cumplirán con sus metas de
emisión de aquí a 2030
estamos avanzando en nuestra parte para
evitar el infierno climático que el
secretario general de las Naciones
Unidas nos advirtió el inicio de esta
semana no estamos ignorando las señales
que ya están acá esto es cierto ha
habido tantos desastres crisis
climáticas que han tocado muy duro
países de esa comunidades a los que
tienen dos menos lo menos recursos para
responder y recuperarse por eso es que
el año pasado me comprometí a trabajar
con nuestro congreso para cuadruplicar
el respaldo estadounidense a las
finanzas climáticas y dar 11 mil
millones de dólares anualmente de aquí a
2024 incluyendo tras mil millones de
dólares para la adaptación por eso es
que el plan de foto de emergencia para
la adaptación y la resiliencia
es lo que llamamos prepare busca tener
medio
500 millones de personas listas para el
cambio climático ya estamos
preparándonos a que sea más personas de
aquí a finales de este año vamos a
buscar que este y nuestros otros
objetivos climáticos sea completamente
patrocinados y hoy
como un primer pago estamos viendo 250
millones de dólares el iniciativas que
respaldan específicamente esfuerzos de
preparación en todo África incluyendo la
adaptación en África esfuerzo que Egipto
y los Estados Unidos lanzaron juntos en
junio esto incluye el respaldo de la
expansión de sistema de alerta temprana
para cubrir a África
el acceso a finanzas climáticas
protección al riesgo climático
fortaleciendo la seguridad climática
movilizando el sector privativo privado
y respaldar
un nuevo centro de entrenamiento aquí en
Egipto para celebrar la adaptación
en todo el continente
Mi misión
mi administración también ha hecho que
los Estados Unidos sea el primer
contribuyente al fondo de adaptación el
año pasado y este año estamos duplicando
nuestra contribución para llevar este
conflicto de 100 millones de dólares nos
estamos asegurando también de que cada
dólar que entreguemos vaya
tan lejos posible
para desbloquear finanzas
sabemos que el dinero es necesario
señores también vamos a respaldar un
escudo global una iniciativa del g7 para
proteger mejor a los países vulnerables
de las pérdidas climáticas y responder
también rápidamente al daño relacionado
con el clima el g7 la alianza del g7
para la infraestructura global y la
inversión está trabajando para
entender y cumplir con estas necesidades
en países debajo del medio ingreso Y nos
enfocamos particularmente en el clima un
proyecto que está facilitando
la consecución de transparencia de
alianzas de la protección para los
trabajadores y el medio ambiente uno de
los muchos proyectos que ya están en
curso es una alianza entre las firmas
estadounidenses y el gobierno de Angola
para invertir los mil millones de
dólares en la construcción de nuevos
proyectos solares en Angola y en
cualquier parte como cualquier parte del
mundo la adaptación cae en África está
buscando combatir las emisiones a la vez
que mejores trabajos Buscar un mejor
crecimiento económico y no dejar a nadie
atrás a medida que implementamos esta
meta estas metas de desarrollo
sostenibles señores este estos han sido
unos años difíciles los desafíos
interconectados que enfrentamos pueden
parecer bastante consumidores y todo lo
que estamos viendo alrededor del mundo
especialmente el ataque
brutal de Rusia contra con ella
exacerbando la carestía alimenticia y
Los costos energéticos y se
incrementando la volatilidad de los
mercados energéticos estamos hablando
también de inflación global
es más urgente que nunca entender que
tenemos que fortalecer nuestros
compromisos climáticos la guerra de
Rusia solamente fortalece la urgencia de
la transición del mundo fuera de la
dependencia de los combustibles fósiles
la seguridad energética significa que
cada nación se beneficia se beneficie de
energía limpia diversificada
ninguna acción ninguna acción puede
tomarse sin que una nación entienda que
puede usar energía como un arma Y hacer
que todos sean Rehenes eso tiene que
detenerse esta reunión debe ser el
momento de comprometer nuestro futuro y
nuestras capacidades compartidas de
escribir una mejor historia para el
mundo
mejoremos nuestro Progreso climático en
el mundo aumentemos nuestras ambiciones
y la agilidad de nuestros esfuerzos las
señales son devastadoramente claras
tenemos que hacer un progreso vital de
aquí a final de esta década por eso es
que Estados Unidos está reuniendo al
mundo alrededor de los activistas
climáticos
relación iniciativa de la comisión
europea la presidenta de la comisión
la llamamos La promesa global por el
metano
en Glasgow esto se aumentó a 100 países
además de 130 países que
se han unido para cubrir más de la mitad
de las emisiones de metano del mundo el
metano es 80% más fuerte que el carbono
y es la mitad es responsable la mitad
del calentamiento global que estamos
enfrentando ahora recortando el metano
las emisiones de metano al 30% puede ser
la mejor oportunidad para mantenernos en
esa meta del 1.8 de 1.8 grados de
temperatura
Hoy estamos
divulgando un plan de acción sobre el
metano y esto describe como Estados
Unidos está involucrado hemos invertido
más de 20.000 millones de dólares en
mitigación de emisiones de metano
para acabar con las fugas mejorar
los equipos industriales para acabar con
estas emisiones también establece unas
acciones regulatorias bastante fuertes
incluyendo una nueva propuesta de
nuestra acción de protección
medioambiental para fortalecer los
estándares sobre metano en todos los
sectores especialmente en los Súper
emisores solamente para asegurarnos que
esto no se ha liberado en comunidades y
que impacte a la salud pública
todos estos pasos
reducirán las emisiones de metano de los
Estados Unidos
al menos
en un 87% de los niveles del 2005 al
2030 Esto es algo que puede cambiar la
situación
se trata de conservar nuestro ambiente
natural sean
los bosques del Congo aquí en África
o el Amazonas en Sudamérica
o los bosques húmedos en Estados Unidos
preservando una de las soluciones más
importantes climáticas que tenemos
algunas que
los pueblos indígenas
[Música]
las comunidades que han sido realmente
las cuidadoras de esas situaciones ellos
lo saben aquí en el 27 somos como
presidentes de la alianza climática por
el medio ambiente mundial para detener
la deforestación La mejor parte de esto
es que no tenemos que desarrollar
ninguna tecnología nueva solamente
tenemos que
dejar Claro que los bosques son más
valiosos cuando son preservados que
cuando son destruidos
[Aplausos]
aquellos que pudieran contribuir
deberían hacerlo aquellos países
realmente
deben preservar estos bosques
importantes estamos reuniendo aliados en
el sector público el escritor privado
para que el ecosistema saludable esté en
el corazón de las economías saludables
Esto va a requerir un esfuerzo de todos
necesitamos reunir nuestra capacidad
para enfrentar las emisiones los
sectores económicos como en el
transporte mundial marítimo
si el sector
de transporte fuera una economía única
sería la décima en términos de emisión
estamos aquí lanzando un desafío verde
del transporte durante esta copa hemos
visto compromisos docenas de gobiernos
de puertos compañías privadas para
facilitar estos envíos privados y
lineales el sector con la meta del 1.5
grados centígrados
si pudiésemos acelerar las acciones en
estas situaciones que pueden cambiar
todo podríamos lograr nuestra meta
mantenerla bajo alcance pero
para
doblar esta curva de misiones cada país
tiene que participar en esta Cumbre
tenemos que renovar y aumentar nuestras
ambiciones climáticas Estados Unidos ha
actuado todo el mundo tiene que actuar
es un deber y una responsabilidad de
Liderazgo global países que están en una
posición de ayudar deberían estar
respaldando a los países en desarrollo
para que puedan tomar decisiones
decisivas respecto del clima facilitando
una transición energética construyendo
un camino a la prosperidad
compatible con nuestro imperativo
climático si los países pueden financiar
el carbón en países en desarrollo no
debe haber razón por la cual no podemos
financiar la energía limpia en los
países en desarrollo
me complace a anunciar hoy junto a la
Unión Europea y Alemania
un paquete de 500 mil dólares para
financiar la transición egipcia a la
energía limpia
[Aplausos]
este paquete permitirá en Egipto
entregar 100 GB de energía renovable
aquí a 2030
mientras desmontan las
instalaciones ineficientes del sector
del gas
también vamos a trabajar con Egipto para
capturar
14.000 millones de gas natural que está
emanando de fugas de sus operaciones y
de vida Esta cooperación Egipto ya ha
elevado su ambición climática y ha
presentado una contribución Superior y
diferente si queremos ganar si vamos a
ganar esta batalla cada gran nación
emisora debe alinearse con esta meta de
1.5 grados centígrados no podemos seguir
apelando la ignorancia de la
consecuencia de nuestras acciones o
seguir repitiendo nuestros errores todos
tienen que acelerar esos esfuerzos en
esta década tan decisiva amigos
combine a la presidencia determinado
al ser cambios transformacionales
cambios necesarios
que necesita ser Estados Unidos y que
debemos hacer todo el resto del mundo
para superar décadas de oposición y
obstáculos al Progreso en este tema nada
más para restablecer Estados Unidos como
un líder confiable respecto del clima
siempre de ustedes diciendo que hemos
tomado grandes logros para hacerlo
grandes
pero no estoy aquí solo
este Progreso ha sido motivado por gente
joven en todo Estados Unidos así como la
gente joven de todo el mundo yo sienten
la urgencia del clima de las siete
profundamente y están comprometidos con
estos temas Ellos saben lo que está en
juego y es el mundo de ellos El que
estamos creando
no se trata de parar y permitirnos
fracasar en esta responsabilidad no
podemos por eso es que mientras observo
todas las cosas que hemos logrado hay
mucho más por hacer y siento igual
optimismo por todo el trabajo que sigue
por hacerse
tenemos que entender que ha habido
grandes progresos Estados Unidos ha
tomado pasos fuertes para cumplir con
sus metas estamos cumpliendo con
nuestras promesas de Liderazgo y cada
vez más el mundo está de nuestro lado
a través de una diplomacia determinada a
través del encuentro de consenso la
construcción de entendimientos en nuevos
enfoques y
inspiradora de tanta gente joven de la
sociedad civil de los activistas
climáticos de las comunidades indígenas
Realmente está galvanizando el mundo Sí
el desafío que enfrentamos es gigante
pero nuestra capacidad es mayor que
nuestros desafíos no podemos dudar de
esto
tratemos de hablar tratemos de tomar el
futuro en nuestras manos y hacer que el
mundo que queremos ver sea realidad que
sabemos que necesitamos
un planeta que es el preservado para
generaciones por venir una economía
empoderada por Fuentes energéticas
limpias oportunidades que se desbloquean
a través de la innovación y la
cooperación que entregan
un gusto más justo para nuestros un
mundo más justo para los niños por eso
es que estamos acá por eso es que
estamos trabajando acá podemos hacerlo
juntos en Google la confianza muchas
muchas gracias que Dios los bendiga a
todos
[Aplausos]